Now that we formally recognize that this is a quadratic equation, it would be
really great if we could get it in the form x minus a times x minus b, so
we could easily see what values of x satisfy this equation. This is going to
be way easier to solve if we have two linear factors multiplied together.
Than if we have to deal with this messy squared term right here. So,
let's take a second and just look at this product for a moment. Now, actually to
make your life a little bit easier, I changed those minus signs to plus signs.
So we now have the expression x plus a, times x plus b. Now,
as a starting point for working with this expression x plus a times x plus b.
I'd like you to try distributing the multiplication here out, and
writing the answer that you get as a polynomial in standard form.